right good morning
so clearly yesterday there was a session
here on functional programming and I'm
guessing that we were talking high
school the problem is this won't compile
because Haskell is case sensitive so
always keep these things in mind when
you're writing stuff up on these and
actually I think that in here there was
a deeper subtext about brexit maybe just
nothing maybe that's that maybe that's
what we're saying I don't know yeah I'm
not a betting I'm not a betting person I
am going to talk a little bit about
probabilities and estimation but I doubt
I don't bet but it is interesting that
if you actually want to know you know I
keep getting asked as I travel Kevin
what's happening with brexit because
originally was gonna be today which is
why I booked an earlier flight than
normal so that I could make sure I could
actually travel you know and people can
you ask me kept me what's happening with
Breck sir and I say well it's a little
bit like the weather you know if you ask
me what's the weather now I'd say look
out the window because you know five
minutes time it could be different yeah
so it does actually turn out the best
way to find out about brexit is to go to
the betting sites they have far better
insight on the probabilities and so it's
quite interesting and watching those
change anyway curiously enough we're not
here to talk about that but I might be
mildly obsessed with it we're here to
talk about this agility does not equal
speed and I want to talk about therefore
what we mean by speed I also wanna talk
about what we mean by agility and yeah
and there you go I'm very I'm easily
storable so I have it I have an interest
in a number of things
software architecture and patterns being
one of them but one of the things about
patterns is that they are intended to be
empirical this is a this is a subtlety
often lost on people
that you're supposed to try something
and say well hang on does this work is
this the right context for this they're
not supposed to be a blind application
of some kind of blueprint that is
definitely not about it so there is this
idea
of exploration and in the original
patterns work by Christopher Alexander
and patterns came not from software but
from building architecture Chris
Maggie's under advocates an approach
that we would call that he calls
piecemeal growth but we would call
typically its receive an incremental
development ok he's sort of saying well
you know you have an idea about how
building might turn out but you need to
treat that as a little more exploratory
contingent and actually see whether or
not your design works in the context as
you are building it and whether or not
people come up with new ideas as they
are building it but I'm also very
interested in the detail because that's
where that's where systems happen when
we talk about architecture where does
architecture happen it doesn't happen in
some kind of vague atmosphere of
possibility it actually comes down to
actual code when we talk about agile
development a lot of people have got
distracted by management practices and
process practices forgetting that that
is all in support of something and that
thing is the software people focused on
the agile but not the software
development it is the manifesto for
agile software development and that's
kind of important it is there to serve a
purpose
this happens in the detail and the
detail is where the surprises happen
details like case sensitivity and if you
have a good eye for detail and you spot
things in the real world for example a
couple of years ago I received a package
and my wife said are you going to open
it I said hell no not until I've taken a
photograph you know world is filled with
beautiful coincidences so I thought I'm
gonna take advantage of this but it also
allows us to figure out okay what do we
mean by this stuff what is what is this
stuff at all and we can go out and look
on look on the internet and sort of look
at the various standard responses to do
that just offer development but I'm kind
of a kind of a dictionary guy in a words
guy so we go and dig in my dictionary it
already tells me a lot more than most
most books on agile do
agile first thing it's an adjective it's
a very simple observation yeah the point
here is that it tells you that it is not
a thing that you can do it's a thing
that you can be you don't do agile and
you can do scrum you can do XP you can
do Kanban
but you are or you know you are more or
less agile and perhaps you were six
months ago you know that team is more
agile than that team we can also apply
it to other things because it is an
adjective it is a property of something
it's an observable property so therefore
we need to observe okay this is a very
very important idea so organizations
that are doing agile transformations is
just a kind of often missing the point
this is this piecemeal growth it doesn't
just apply to the things that we build
it applies to the way that we interact
this is quite important so we need to
observe observation will tell you an
awful lot if we can apply it to code
bases we can apply it to architectures
we can apply to organizations because it
has a very simple meaning able to move
quickly and easily and I'm able to say
it's no use me having an agile mindset
if my code has a very different opinion
of that okay it's just like hey we're an
agile team we're totally yeah we're
going that way and the code says are you
going that way yeah this is a really
important point that the thing that you
are working with also has to play along
a few years ago I picked up the small
piece of trivia that the turning circle
of an oil tanker is around five or six
kilometers so if you've forgotten your
keys that's tough the turning circle of
a skateboard is like zero now this is an
important consideration because there's
something else here that's going on
we've got this idea of able to move
quickly and easily it's those two
properties these are observable
properties now what's really interesting
here is that most of the time when you
hear it somehow the second bit gets
forgotten they just go for the speed
that quickly we were here before
25 years ago rapid application
development rat or rabbit applique
development there were issues with
quality mistakes were made but this is
how we tend to focus on these things and
this all fits in with a kind of a
general emphasis on something that is
more immediately observable which is
speed and this also relates to the thing
that we build so Blaise Pascal wrote
this I've made this letter longer than
usual because I have not had the time to
make it shorter
I've seen this attributed to all kinds
of people it is it is Pascal it is
Blaise Pascal because you can actually
find the original French it was written
in the 17th century so if you know the
Internet is filled with possible
possible alternatives yeah so it's
there's no maybe this is the truth the
most interesting thing here when we
start talking about things like quality
are and the scale of our code and the
complexity of our systems it turns out
that it all hinges on something that we
are surprisingly poor at dealing with
something that we live in and yet do not
fully appreciate time it's a little bit
like we didn't really understand air
until relatively recently and yet humans
have been breathing air for a really
long time we live in time but we're very
poor as creatures of time and
understanding how it works and this
leads to all kinds of really interesting
thinkers and shortcuts so this this is
an experience from a couple years back
it's talking wonderful ah he said I
can't get this co-working well did you
check it before integrating it yes I
checked it in the interpreter did it
work there no it's kinda like is a
hurry's kind of like there's a notion
here of urgency it doesn't work there so
maybe it'll work here this is a this is
a brilliant thing this is the opposite
of it'll it works on my machine it
doesn't work on my machine but baby
maybe it'll just work in production just
just this yeah people don't give enough
people don't pay enough attention to the
opposite of it works on my machine and
that's sometimes but while in production
it's special it's got it's got magic
fairy dust that makes things work maybe
just maybe it'll work and this also
hints at something else and
with wit we're terrible we are optimists
we otherwise you wouldn't be doing
software development yeah
it's baked into your DNA but this
urgency that drives us to do things
which when presented in the cold light
of day look clearly that's ridiculous
why would you do that people don't
people don't present themselves or the
things that they do in life as little
stories to be told in talks like this
that's not how it works that's only an
observation after the fact what happens
is that you are in the moment and our
ability to understand the pressures on
us are not very good and the urgency the
speed we also have mantras that kind of
encourage us down this path now Facebook
didn't put Facebook didn't come up with
this this is actually an old engineering
adage move fast and break things which
is absolutely brilliant until you start
saying yeah let's break politics or
let's break client dependencies let's
break all of these things there's a
notion here the obsession with speed
again this is a problem because it turns
out that this is this is really well
actually let's put it this way a lot of
people don't call it speed in the agile
space they call it velocity now
somewhere in my deep and distant past I
have a degree in physics which makes me
very upset by this because these are not
the same it turns out that velocity has
direction
it turns out that matters and what most
teams when they are talking about
velocity are talking about is magnitude
but not direction they are talking about
some notion of speed direction matters I
had this experience a number of years
ago driving trying to navigate oh let's
see
Belgium Netherlands to Germany I was
driving this is pre this is pre Google
Maps and I didn't have a sat-nav on me
so I just relied on Microsoft or
route the I know there are Microsoft
employees in this room I want you to
feel embarrassed
[Applause]
Microsoft autoroute which turns out has
a little bit of an issue with
localization it has this rather sweet
idea that there are only two languages
you ever need to worry about the
language of deployment in this case
English and the language of the country
that you are driving in that's great if
you have a country with only one
language but when you are driving
through Belgium this does not work and
unfortunately it turns out that all the
names that we have in England for places
in Belgium are the French names this
does not work when you are not in the
french-speaking part so I'm there
driving thinking like hang on I'm trying
to figure out is that the same there and
then I see the Sun the Sun is in the
wrong place I am driving it speed round
the Ring Road and I'm you know I'm
sitting like I'm making gravy I've got
good speed I'm looking forward to the
speed that I will get when I cross the
German border but I've got great speed
just in the wrong direction the Sun is
not where it should be it turns out I
would have been better walking at that
point this is important a lot of teams
are heading in the wrong direction and
what do we mean by the wrong direction
well sometimes we're talking in terms of
the product feature set sometimes we're
talking in terms of the organizational
goals most often and most visibly we're
talking about the internal qualities of
what they are building we're tearing out
a great speed we are just through and we
are just massing out technical debt we
are building the wrong thing in the
wrong way and we are going to pay the
price for that one day so there is this
idea that we need to care a little bit
about direction but even if we reduce it
to just the speed dimension that gave us
a question what do we mean by the speed
the magnitude its displacement of stuff
whose displacement of s with respect to
time more formally written like that but
let's keep it simple my kids are doing
my younger child is doing this suvat
equations at school so let's keep it
nice and simple this so we need to
figure out what s is for us t is for
time
V is velocity reduced to speed s is
stuff now you can stop me if you think
I'm getting too technical its stuff it's
the amount of stuff per time now we need
to figure out what the nature of stuff
is one way of dealing with this is stuff
we have left to do and this is a burn
down chart stuff we have left to do over
time here's an idealized burned out char
we have less stuff to do burn down
chance can be very useful I tend to
focus more on build up charts how much
stuff have we done or how much stuff
have we got there's another way of
looking at it if you want to combine
both views you can do things like
humanistic flow diagrams but I'm not
really here to talk about the
diagramming exactly as the nature of the
axis that we're dealing with here I mean
first of all I I'm a little bit
suspicious whenever I look at diagrams
and they have straight lines the real
world doesn't work like this but also
there's this notion that having a
constant speed is necessarily a good
thing actually I don't think it is if
you're undertaking work that is new that
is novel and you've never dealt with
before constant speed is not really
where you want to be you want to be
picking up speed you want to start slow
and comfortable and as your knowledge
increases you want to be picking up
speed
so actually starting at that speed is
not really where you want to be going
but there's another interesting thing we
might have to be a little more precise
about the words stuff and what is the
nature of stuff what is it that we are
accumulating and this is where it starts
getting tricky because in the world of
physics it turns out there's an awful
lot of things that you can measure that
are that have standardized units but
what is the stuff that we measure and
sometimes people talk about business
value well they just talk simply about
value the problem is with the word value
is that it's not entirely clear that
what you value is what something else
values and do you value
work-life balance or is somebody talking
about valuing money and she leads to
this one yes the planet got destroyed
but for a beautiful moment in time we
created a lot of value for shareholders
yeah only not much value elsewhere but
the notion there is even with that
that's value for shareholders what about
value for the company directly what
about value for the customer these are
all these are all financial in some way
but there's another thing here that we
need to be very very careful of when
people talk about prioritization with
respect to business value there is a
problem with this this is a very
standard mantra in the agile space you
prioritize you should prioritize your
features your requirements with respect
to business value that sounds brilliant
there's any one problem it's impossible
I actually know it's not completely
impossible if you have a time machine
which I do clearly if you have a time
machine you can do this because how do
you know the business value of something
well in the future I can look back and
tell you well that was worth this but
now I can't tell you what the business
value is I can tell you what an estimate
of the business value is but that is
entirely different estimates are not the
same as the thing that they are
estimating estimates are probability
distributions they are ranges there are
lots of different ways of looking at it
so when somebody says we are going to
prioritize by business value you just
put in no now you're gonna prioritize by
an estimation of business value you need
to add that note of caution in there
because an estimate basically tells you
that there is information that we are
using in order to get a range of result
and we could be wrong we could be wrong
in a very good way we could also be
wrong in a very bad way but you are
prioritizing with respect to estimates
and it should add a note of humility so
what else can we do
well lines of code yeah that this is
what code generators were created for to
gain that yeah so no that doesn't work
out
so eventually people settle on very
abstract units things like story points
there's any of is that this there's a
problem here though with which sometimes
people don't realize they walking into
if we do a very simple bit of
dimensional analysis time is measured
with respect to time that's cool
what a story points actually although
they're not supposed to be they end up
being translated via a conversion rate
to time so you're measuring time against
time
I remember pointing this out to a scrum
master once it was just I was looking he
was such deep such care over doing this
manual plot on on a wall such detail
such care and attention it's one of
those things pull back and look at the
big picture you're plotting time against
time what does that actually mean I mean
it does mean things it just probably
doesn't mean what you hoped it meant
it's not an indication of speed it it's
an indication of utilization hey in an
eight-hour day if I spent five hours
working directly on proton product work
then my utilization is five-eighths yeah
six to 2.5 percent so that's okay now is
that useful I don't know it's a it's a
figure it's a number but I don't know if
that's what we want alternatively it
gives us a quality of estimation how
good are our estimates so that's another
work thing that it could be measuring
but the one thing is not measuring is
how much stuff we've actually got how
much capability our system has how much
functionality it has so it turns out
that if we want to if we actually want
to develop products that have
appropriate quality and get delivered in
appropriate time frames and importantly
have appropriate longevity as it turns
out that we our obsession with I need to
hit the next release I heat and need to
hit the next release does not balance
out well with the idea that this is a
game that continues you don't actually
hit need to hit the next release you
need to hit all of the next
that gives you a completely different
perspective but humans are not very good
at that that's what caused the 2008
credit crisis well there's a technical
term for it intertemporal judgment I
think it is yeah the ability to balance
trade-offs at two different points in
time feel free to drop that into a
meeting at some point you know I think
I'd intertemporal judgment or whatever
yeah that sounds good so we need to
pause a little bit so how we're going to
pause so here's the OODA loop John Boyd
friend of mine John Jagger often talks
about this one he introduced me to it as
with Boyd was a US Air Force pilot and
kind of wrote the book on aerial combat
in high speed fighters and as is often
the way most things that a military end
up somewhere in business speak at some
point in the 1990s Sun Tzu's Art of War
was a must read for for people in
business and we've kind of moved to
other various things so dude is kind of
interesting because there's this whole
notion when people think oh yeah fighter
jets they're thinking they're thinking
Top Gun and it's all of it it's all
about the need for speed it's all about
the speed but actually when you look at
what they're doing it's it's very
different observe orient decide act it
turns out that most of this is not about
the bit that you see or the bit that is
dramatized there's a kind of like okay
what's going on where do we actually
want to be how are we going to do that
now I'm going to rotate this through 180
degrees just for fun now I'm going to
rotate it 380 degrees because John and I
were once running a workshop and you
know everybody collects their own
favorite loops and he had the you do
loop and I I tend to favor a different
loop and I we were trying to decide
which one should we include and it was
anyone I rotated it I suddenly thought
wait a minute these are the same pts a
plan do study act sometimes called plan
do check out
the word Act means something slightly
different in this case it's where do two
is to do in in Boyds oder loop but the
basic principles are surprisingly
similar and what is interesting here is
there is a notion it's just starts in a
different place it's like a slightly
different mode but here we have the idea
of we are going to plan and when we talk
about plan I use the word plan in its
broadest sense plan can refer to
something in space a building plan we
can also refer something in time a
schedule so go back to the relativistic
fun
this is space time okay so plan
basically means I think we're going to
do this and I have a hypothesis I
believe we can do this we're going to do
it then we're going to reflect on it
study it and then we're gonna act on it
now what is interesting here
historically that this is the Democrat
cycle originally it was formulators plan
do study act many people know it's PDCA
plan-do-check-act but one of the things
I like is the word study why do I like
the word study because it's slow yeah if
you just think about it you know if you
check that yeah checked done study oh
that's gonna take a bit of time yeah
yeah mild a mild boy last year did a
whole bunch of exams you know my wife
and I did not merely encourage him to
check his work we encouraged him to
study yeah there's some really big
difference one takes a lot longer than
the other but that's the idea you're
supposed to go into it in depth now the
problem here is that that is a
deliberate act of slowing down the other
problem is visibility if you look the
things at the top half are highly
visible if you think about what a team
is doing I can see planning I can see
the consequence of planning I can see
doing I can see the consequences of
doing but studying and acting on that
and putting in trying things out that's
a little less visible and because it's
not visible
humans are not very good at dealing with
things they cannot directly see we're
great with physical things that we can
kick but we're not really good with
stuff that is less visible time is a
less visible thing for one thing but as
a study and act now we might say well
you know this is all
this is all very well but this is all
very recent in terms of how we
appreciate this in the software industry
typically the tyranny of software
development has been oh you know since
the 1970s we've all we were you know the
company culture is dominated with plan
do not plan do study act but plan do we
do a lot of planning then we do a lot of
doing okay that's that's a sequential
process that is a waterfall process you
know so yeah it's difficult to throw
this off you know is we're only now
learning that software development is
more nuanced it's filled with discovery
and observation yeah only now learning
so software engineering is a term that
dates back to the mid 1960s it was not
invented for this conference this is a
landmark conference that nobody ever
reads the Proceedings of so a couple of
years ago I decided I would read the
Proceedings of it I'm one of those kind
of old fashioned guys who likes to read
the things that he cites I know it's
very unfashionable now but I just
thought I'd sit there and read what they
actually said people normally cite this
as being the big the birth of software
engineering as creating the word
software engineering as encouraging us
to use plan driven metaphors as the
origin of the phrase software crisis it
was the origin of the phrase software
crisis but they're about two pages and
the whole proceedings dedicated to that
nobody ever talks about it in the rest
of the conference okay so we've got a
very distorted view of what goes on here
and one of the greatest revelations of
this was this it turns out that Andy
Kinslow is not the only person in the
document to say the design process is an
iterative one there are loads of people
I can literally fill a whole talk with
quotes from that paper that indicate
that we must be very careful about
trying to take a strictly plan driven
approach that it's filled with this so
we lost some knowledge somewhere I would
say and people often wonder what
happened what happened in the 1970s
flairs disco you know these to blame
however this also tells us something
else and this this is where it starts
getting interesting
so what am I
authors Neil Gaiman observes you have to
finish things that's what you learn from
you learn by finishing things now if I
have a project that I can spend 18
months on I have one point of completion
in 18 months time that is my major point
of learning we start the project at the
we will never know less in that 18 month
span than we do at the beginning it is
not but we will never know less we might
feel increasingly ignorant as the
whereas we discover more but that's a
relative knowledge our knowledge is
actually growing our appreciation of
what we don't know also grows but we
will never notice at the beginning if we
make all the critical decisions there
that's not so smart but there is a point
here that the main point of learning the
main point of feedback where we go aha
and there it is so perhaps we should
finish smaller things we should finish
more often we should finish less
ambitious things and that will allow us
more piecemeal growth a classic example
of piecemeal growth is something like
refactoring I really ought to update
this Martin's come out with a new
edition of refactoring that uses
JavaScript instead of Java so if you
wanted evidence that we are living in
the end times apparently that's it but
there is a notion here sometimes people
reduce refactoring to simply just like
it's a shortcut that I do for simple
things like renaming and renaming is a
very powerful idea renaming is a
reflection of our own learning but
there's a really important thing here is
that refactoring is much broader it is a
deeper recognition that design has a
both a proactive and a reactive element
it's like I offer something I create
something we see how it works out and
then I respond to what I've now lurked
so design is not a moment it is a
process that is ongoing but if we look
at this improving the design of existing
code it's the subtitle and we need to
focus on the code but we need to be very
careful with the word code because we
often have our own favorite default
definition of what we mean by code and
our favorite default definition is
normally the whatever way my main
programming language is typically the
one that appears on
CV whatever my main programming language
is then that is the code so I'm gonna
see sharp programmer then it's that is
the code I'm a Java programmer that is
the code all that other stuff Oh with a
little bit of JavaScript at the front
end that's not code all that XML I
always love it when people say uh you
might if those with long memories may
remember there was a period 10-15 years
ago where the whole idea well son was
still around so that kind of dates it
they took back 100% Java you have a
hundred percent Java it's just that I
remember looking looking at like you
kidding if you take away the XML there's
no there's no there's no system you have
just bits of Java the XML is holding the
thing together okay so these systems
were never 100% Java they were kind of
mostly your her XML and all your config
stuff all your tests yeah in other words
all of these things and the list goes on
they all use a formal notation that is
your code your build scripts guess what
their code okay all of this is code and
more precisely we can actually look with
a little bit of wordplay this is
codified knowledge this is a different
way of looking at what is a code base a
code base is a knowledge base and we
don't appreciate that because when we we
often think of it as this is a
production artifact it's a specification
it's all kinds of things but what if we
consider this to be an repository of
knowledge this is how we believe the
system is built this is what we
understand of the domain of the problem
and how we understand the technology and
our decisions our design decisions to do
this this is our current state of
thinking and this is effectively what
we're saying here is this is it almost
like a an executable Wikipedia
okay and therefore it tells us that the
very act of development is centered
around knowledge this is knowledge
formulation now I've done this with a
couple of teams where I've mentioned
this and they've kind of looked a little
bit nervous they say sorry so you're
saying our code base is a reflection of
our current knowledge Wow we think
messily
okay with the problem that we have with
a codebase when we recognize it's
codified knowledge is that when I go
into the codebase what I see is what we
currently think what we thought six
months ago what we thought six years ago
and when I say we six years ago it's
people I've never met so in other words
the past and the present are
simultaneous and we're kind of trying to
most of the time we're trying to
negotiate the past in the present
together and that becomes difficult it's
made harder by the fact that humans are
quite capable of holding contradictory
beliefs simultaneously this is difficult
for a code base yeah even in the
presence of maybe so what do we learn
what do we learn we learn is that
therefore either in software development
if one of its goals is codified
knowledge that is executable then the
very process what is the process of
acquiring knowledge versus requiring
knowledge is learning although feel free
to use this phrase you know when you're
talking to higher-ups and you know on
slides because knowledge acquisition
sounds so much more I know it's got
impact you know whereas learning sounds
they're my kids do that but we're in
business we do knowledge acquisition
yeah my children merely learn they go to
school to learn but we are in business
we do knowledge acquisition as business
value and obviously if you can work if
you can work the word synergy in there
or something like that then that's great
yeah yeah we we've got a knowledge
acquisition process that synergizes and
leverages the assets of the team in
order to fulfill business requirements
thus attributing value you can keep this
going you can build pretty much tab
complete this one yeah I will wash my
mouth out afterwards I think that was
disgusting what I just said I'm supposed
to like English so yeah
now how do we get learning now here's an
important thing is that I've been using
the first-person plural we I'm referring
to the people in the room but I'm also
referring to the notion of a team this
is an act of communication learning
happens through communication that's how
we pass knowledge between ourselves and
communication there are many different
channels of communication that we have
we have spoke and communication
you have visual forms whether we're
talking PowerPoint or sketches on a on a
whiteboard but we're also talking a code
we're talking emails we're talking all
of these things all of these things
should be considered to be acts of
communication when I write a test and my
merely testing that something is okay or
am I trying to communicate to somebody
what we anticipate and this is my
understanding of this I'm trying to
communicate my understand it doesn't
mean I'm right but I want to make it I'm
playing an open-hand game okay I want to
make sure that here's what I want you to
see this is what I'm thinking I could be
wrong but if I show you what I'm
thinking you'll be able to see if I hold
it if I hold it close then you won't you
we don't know what's going on it also
means because it all sounds lovely up
until now you know it's kind of like
we're all living on a commune producing
knowledge that sounds fantastic and it
all humans are not we kind of resist the
whole idea of complete cooperation so
there's a social negotiation now this is
quite an interesting one because then we
start realizing that a code base
reflects not many the rational things
and not merely the accidental things it
reflects social structures social
negotiation coding guidelines are often
social negotiations okay this is really
interesting and therefore a design
reflects that there's another aspect
here what you then create is a model of
participation and we've got another word
we've got another phrase that we use for
model of participation it's called
software architecture the software
architecture is not just a technical
construct what you're doing is you're
basically saying this is how we work
this is how we work together this is how
you're expected so with this tooling and
these this code this approach this is
how this team produces stuff this is how
we are able to contribute and move
things forward so you're actually
defining a future path it's a model of
participation so this gets right to the
heart of the matter is it's about us and
speed is not really the right way of
looking at it what we're talking about
here is effectively collective
intelligence okay so as interviewed a
couple years back so we get biggest
advantage of autonomously working teams
is risk reduction through increased
group intelligence risk
has a very risk has formal definition in
the sense of exposure it is exposure to
uncertainty okay so it's not merely a
probability it's whether or not you're
exposed to that probability that that is
that is the that is the issue how do we
understand all the possible things when
we're building software there's an awful
lot that's new in fact this is the point
of software software is the production
of novelty production of variation with
death by definition even if you use even
if you use a whole bunch of standard
tools in a standard space the software
you're creating is in some way new so
what are the risks that you're engaging
in and turns out some of the risks are
to do with predicting the future which
we're not very good at but this is the
notion if you have more people you want
to increase your intelligence that's
what a group of people can do if your
goal is knowledge it's not typing the
goal is knowledge how do you get a lot
of people to create a body of knowledge
that is really very good so there's no
correlation between a groups collective
intelligence and the IQ of its
individual members now if you've been
watching the British Parliament the last
few weeks you can see this in action I
even suspect that it is possible I think
I I think I've always been told that IQ
is a positive number I begin to think
you might have a negative domain however
think about this one so therefore
there's a notion here and this is very
important to appreciate that
that if we're trying to make a group of
people intelligent it's not just good
enough to get a bunch of people together
that does not create that and that there
are some subtleties that can work
against us this one if a group includes
more women it's collective intelligence
Rises now this one came out of a piece
of research I came across this in 2011
and what's interesting is the research
was not setting out to look at that
specifically but it was a an interesting
result and obviously looking at you I
can say you could be smarter but there's
a broader thing here
it's it's a general one of diversity
diversity has many aspects one is
fairness and representation but there's
another one here and we talk about
diversity what we're actually saying is
that if we all think the same then we're
not really thinking are we what's the
value of having you know n people
thinking the same way you could have had
one person thinking the same way and
that would be fine it would be cheaper
on be cheaper if you gonna get something
wrong you might as well do it cheaply
fewer staff but there's a notion here we
have a habit of recruiting in our own
image people from our background whether
we mean our background to be an
educational one where there is an ethic
ethnic one whatever it means it means
that suddenly you've got a lot of people
that think much more narrowly you if you
want group intelligence you can't have
the same people you can't have you can't
recruit from people who are all the same
age I as as I get older I noticed the
age thing a little bit more I go to some
companies and I think I'm the youngest
person here that's worrying and I go to
other companies I think I'm the oldest
person here and actually I'm the same
I'm the same distance from all of these
people in terms of age oh they're all
the same age that's not good either you
go to companies are they're all computer
science graduates mmm you know there's
that that's the same thing what you're
doing is you're thinking the same people
from diverse backgrounds might actually
alter the behavior of group social
majority in ways that lead to improved
more IQ group thinking there's a notion
here about sometimes it's there's an
enforced objectivity but also there's a
notion of it changes the communication
style if you remember our few slides
back I had two a communication now how
we're going to trade stuff it it breaks
the sumption x' assumptions are
difficult creatures because you don't
know you have them until they are
contradicted yeah think about it for a
moment how do you know that you have an
assumption you normally you don't and
then somebody says something and you say
oh I had assumed that at that moment in
that moment you have discovered you had
an assumption
so assumptions are discovered by
contradiction so somebody says oh right
we're going to write down a list of
project assumptions at the beginning of
the project you go for it it won't it
won't be complete if
be completely wrong actually it'll be a
the assumptions that you've discovered
so far which is no not bad it's just
that compared to the assumptions you're
about to discover and that's that's a
take the 18-month time frame you are
going to discover and a lot more
assumptions and those are going to be
from those moments for some oh I'd
assumed that right that was assumption
so there's a notion here that you have a
blind spot you can't see your own
assumptions until they come into
collision with something
so what we're learning here is that
group intelligence is not simply about
number and there's a very subtle
creature you can get this one wrong
whistle crowds by James Surowiecki 2003
he gave us a very simple set of criteria
which i think is still it's still quite
useful for conditions that characterize
wise crowds diversity of opinion
independence decentralization and
aggregation you can't all think the same
way but also you have to be independent
you have to be able to think
independently now this one's quite
difficult because humans are social
animals we tend to converge on things it
turns out that in economics there is
this idea of humans as rational but
selfish and independent
the problem is we're not like that
that's not actually how it works
we are strongly influenced by family
connections friend groups and all the
rest of it so independence is a very
difficult thing to achieve this is one
of the things that can lead to
groupthink even when you are thinking
differently you can accidentally
converge on something again I refer to
the UK Parliament decentralization
importantly you need to be drawing from
different it's not just enough to think
differently you actually need to be
drawing from different things different
resources different bodies of knowledge
that's kind of important now all this is
great but it turns out 3 out of 4 is not
enough because you somehow you need to
bring it all back together again
aggregation where do we aggregate all of
this stuff well that's in conversation
that's in code the code is a place for
aggregation remember it's a model of
participation this is where we put our
knowledge
so this is interesting because one of
the things we're seeing here is that
this is not really about speed this
turns out to be about people and these
relationships if you like it's
individuals and interactions so that's
we've read it really rather important
but you know human beings are obsessed
by obsessed by very simple things you
know and you know the the guy who's
currently in the white house seems to be
massively obsessed with size and in this
he reflects a number of other obsessions
that we find in business and in the
agile space size but to be precise I'm
gonna use the word scale because that is
the word that gets used all over the
place safe scalable agile framework less
large scale scrum we are obsessed with
this there are talks on agile at scale
and he was talking at scale now what I
would like you to do is next time
somebody says how do we scale this I
want you to throw in a very there's
something missing from that sentence
there's an implied thing whenever
somebody implies something or it's it's
tacit it's not explicit see if you can
just sort of nudge it slightly yeah can
we scale this just ask up or down that
should stop the conversation but this is
interesting because there's a hidden
assumption there now that hidden
assumption a couple years ago my oldest
son did a lot of CrossFit and when I
found absolutely fascinating
is that in the CrossFit world the word
scale is used but it means exactly the
opposite of the way we seem to use it if
you scale and exercise you scale it down
so perhaps you have an injury perhaps
you're recovering from an illness and so
perhaps you can't lift all the weights
or do all the reps maybe you're new to
it maybe you dad you haven't built up
the same kind of strength as as other
people the same kind of skill but you
still want to go through the repetitions
of either weightlifting or whatever it
is you scale it but that means to scale
it down so we're you know picking my son
up driving it back home
how'd it go so yeah they were you know
this is pretty good I'd you know do what
I did last time but then I had to add
there a couple things I had to scale and
he means scaled down so there's a notion
here be very careful with these
assumptions that we have with these
words so bigger is not always better it
turns out that if you're going to go
fishing I the smaller boat is better but
a larger boat is surprisingly difficult
to do with this one it also has a much
larger turning circle far less
maneuverable and uses up an awful lot
more fuel it's basically expensive to
run now this is all relevant because we
have something else that the real world
the physical world gives us in terms of
our preconceptions a friend of mine and
Kelly made this very clear observation
software-development does not have
economies of scale it has diseconomies
of scale it turns out that we and this
is this is different to the way the
physical world runs we have economies of
scale in the physical world when I make
when I make more goods that are the same
then they should per unit get cheaper
that's how that's the physical benefits
of mass production but what we produce
in software tends to be unique and novel
so therefore that doesn't really work
adding more people does not
automatically make give you speed up and
in fact we can really understand the
kind of the whole speed-up thing through
just a sec air 'full careful
understanding so if I take as a baseline
t1 this is the completion time for a
piece of work for one person
software development work and I'm going
to say when I say completion time for
one person I mean they are doing
everything if there is testing to be
done they're doing it if there's talking
to the client they're doing it all the
deployment stuff everything this person
is doing absolutely everything so this
is our baseline is how long it takes one
person to do this work then somebody
goes away and reads Adam Smith wealth
nations and they learn about division of
labor this is brilliant because this
actually works for certain things really
well typically physical things
so we end up with that the problem is
that you have to kind of pause for a
moment and say hang on we're gonna get
perfect speed-up no because it depends
on the nature of the task as you may
know if you try and get lots of people
working in the same place on the same
thing in a physical sense they tend to
get in each other's way but also the
nature of the task does not always
divide itself up like that and we end up
with weight States so P is the portion
of the work we can do in parallel if
it's 100% then it means nobody's
communicating and everything that we're
doing is independent but it's going to
be less than that which means there are
weight States there are natural
bottlenecks it's the organization of the
work it also tells us that actually the
lean folks are right on this one reduce
were reduce your work in progress will
give you good better speed up but this
equation looks a little more familiar if
we call it and Al's law this also allows
me to point out that human beings are
not processors yeah this is a thought
experiment I'm making massive
simplifications here but it is designed
to just demonstrate that by default
don't expect massive speed-up this is
just how we have organized our process
we haven't even started talking about
the thing that we're building yet which
means there's another term it turns out
that we might need to talk to each other
or communicate with each other some of
which is done through code some of which
is done face-to-face and so on and that
means the worst-possible-case is where
we're all having to talk to one another
this is a reflection of the architecture
if it's highly coupled then we have to
everybody who has to talk to everybody
else where every code has to talk to
well what do we do about that well
sometimes people get defensive richly in
the code and they start creating
barriers that defend them against other
people's code or allows them to work
more independently that wasn't a
requirement of the architecture is just
a requirement of how people are and
there is an overhead associated with
this now lots of lots of equations what
people really want is a graph so here's
a graph
what you can see here is with some
degree of satisfaction if you have zero
people it will take infinite time yeah
that's great I mean when somebody says
how's it going same as last week you can
always provide a consistent answer but
you can say there are no bugs positive
that's good now as we start to add
people we get a speed-up but then that
starts slowing down because now we've
kind of maxed out what we can reasonably
get you finished early
they've finished earlier that's not fair
we've we can't get more from this
because people are communicating as
effectively as possible for the nature
of the task if we start adding more
people then we actually are introducing
overheads we are now paying the cost of
adding more people we're not getting
benefit from it we're now adding we
start slowing down
lots of consultancies operate out here
but the problem here is that we end up
with we end up with a problem that we
can easily characterized as this
slowdown we are paying a cost it's is
actually half the energy that we're
expending half the effort and the money
is actually on the side effects of
having so many people it's actually
nothing to do with the work now what's
interesting about this is that we what
we're saying here is that the actual
size that and guess what by the way the
size of the codebase will grow as a
result it turns out that it is
surprisingly difficult to create a small
codebase with lots of people and this is
a this is a reflection sometimes people
think ok it's this kind of task we'll
need this many people and we'll take
this amount of time but we fail to visit
this the assumption that the
functionality doesn't tell you how much
code or how many people particularly
things about software development it's
like
big Darwinian experiment look around the
planet and you can actually see lots of
different teams doing things that are
quite similar and there are very
different sizes and sometimes they're
actually building something to the same
specification or similar specification
and you're saying well how come this
company's got like you know 50
developers and this one's got five tell
you what the route with five is probably
gonna finish first yeah because these
other guys are carrying slike the rocket
equation is like you're carrying most of
your fuel you're gonna have to you the
actual energy expended in getting
everybody to work together is itself
huge and you can simply realize that it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy the
more people you put on a project the
larger the project will be ending and
this is quite difficult now again I want
to remind you that this is a
approximation based on a simplified
thought experiment because honestly if
the curve were as simple as that in the
real world you'd immediately know when
you were slowing down but you can't so
the real world is there's so much
additional variability that you end up
with an awful lot of stuff local local
minima and local Maxima that you can't
see that you're in and so therefore
adding a person may slow it down but
adding another person may speed it up or
vice versa just depends on the people
you can't always tell where you are but
I was fortunate enough to see in action
many years ago a manager who half the
size of a team he half the size of a
team and brought her a late project back
on schedule so that's why the company
got rid of him because he made everybody
else look bad I loved working for him he
was great because he used to sit there
and mostly not apparent he used to sit
there and kind of think he didn't do
things with spreadsheets he sat there
trying to figure out what's actually
going on with this team or this company
what could I do that would make this
more effective or cause less
interruption this is now a much more
normal thing to be encouraged but at the
time it was utterly foreign to me I'd
never seen anything like this but he
made all the other managers look bad so
they kind of got rid of him that's how
people work disappointingly okay so I
mentioned Christopher Alexander earlier
on as being the kind of
of patents movement but his work in the
1960s actually was also quite
interesting and quite provocative and a
number of people were inspired by this
in a in an interdisciplinary sense
there's book notes on the synthesis of
form so my copy of it here he talks
about how systems of things or anything
evolves and he says we may therefore
picture the process of filmmaking as the
action of a series of subsystems all
interlinked yet sufficiently free of one
another to adjust independently in a
feasible amount of time you know there
was this idea either in the software or
in the people that you have groups but
there's a kind of don't couple people
too closely just allow enough variation
because as they learn as they try things
they will introduce variation and if
everybody couples too tightly then that
will ripple out that means you end up
with everybody having to talk to
everybody else it's as it was because
the cycles of Correction and rhe
correction which occurred during
adaptation are restricted to one
subsystem at a time
what I find fascinating is that this was
cited in the 1968 software engineering
conference proceedings it was cited in
multiple locations this was very
influential and this was people saying
are we need to partition our systems but
also our teams so that as we learn
things may change these days we use
other terminology like refactoring and
so on and the very strong emphasis on
modularity again modularity was a word
that was used extensively but turns out
that so here's a sort of visual
representation in doing some work it was
anyone putting together a talk like
something weight-loss they used this
right next to it was this slide it turns
out in the 1960s everybody was drawing
bubble diagrams in the 1980s people
started drawing rectangular diagrams
which came to dominate in the 1990s I
look forward to the next decade and
seeing what shape you know we've had
hexagonal architecture the last year all
right you know what are we gonna choose
next I'm really excited because it turns
out there's loads of shapes and math
that we have yet to explore so but what
this one is as a picture this is taken
from Melvin Conway's how do you
committees invent paper this is the
paper that gave us Conway's law and very
importantly he was interested in this
stuff
basic thesis is
which design system are constrained to
produce designs which are copies of the
communication structures of these
organizations a lot of people miss that
subtlety and they think they it copies
the organizational structure no copies
the communication structure of the
organization which may or may not
correspond to the magic diagram that
shows you who's in charge of who yeah
humans are a little bit messier than
that we communicate in ways that are
defined by geography by friendship by
how long we've been at the company I
would expect somebody who's been at a
company for 20 years to have completely
a very broad communication network
compared to somebody who's been there
for two years so we need to look at that
but also and what I find interesting is
that some people have referred to the
idea of a this I noticed this a few
years ago people there there's an
inverse Conway or a reverse Conway
maneuver which sounds really cool which
is when you reverse the idea of Conway's
law these people did not recon West
paper this is exactly what he says at
the end he doesn't just say your
software architecture is gonna be a
necessary is is a victim of your
organizational structure he tells you
how to take control of it he tells you
figure out what you want and then
organize according to the need for
communication organize your people
according we want this architecture ok
how are people organized you know who
communicates with who oh ok well that's
not going to support this architecture
so maybe we need to change this or this
that's a really simple idea
now we're heating this idea of Conway's
so we discussed Conway quite a lot in
them proposed a five book but we made a
real observation refer to this as a law
the appeal is to the force that will
shape a system much as a physical law
it's not a law of the country you can't
break it it's just there so the force is
there how do you counterbalance it and
we can kind of look at this there's no
that don't worry this one's not gonna
fall out the sky it's an Airbus not a
Boeing well this is important because it
turns out that the Boeing thing Boeing
737 max it wasn't really a software
fault it's actually a basic aerodynamic
fault
engines are in the wrong place for the
structure and it would help if they went
back to the original for force diagram
that is used to illustrate this stuff
you've got gravity gravity stands out is
not really that negotiable
but importantly when I get into an
airplane and fly I am NOT disobeying the
law of gravity so haha look at me
breaking the law no that's not how it
works there is a delicate balance
between a number of other things which
are mediated by the weight the
aerodynamics and and all the rest of it
that that is what gives us Aeronautics
now clearly don't take this too
literally because this is about people
and software rather than about something
playing physical but I'd like to make
you think in these terms that when
you're talking about this stuff there is
a balance of things there is a force
that is exerted upon the team that is
based on how it communicates by default
there is a driving thrust design effort
but that can be held back by debt and
your practice hopefully is the lift
obviously as I say don't take this too
literally you can put your own favorite
four things in there and you can
rearrange them but the idea here is to
appreciate that there is an interaction
between these that there is a balance to
be achieved that is not really that
simple it's not a simple one
one-dimensional thing so back to the
basic physics you can put a lot of force
into stuff you can put a lot of force on
something how much acceleration you get
well a heavier it is the less
acceleration you get M is for mass M is
for monoliths so this is your original
legacy system this is one of the very
latest computers to roll off the brexit
production line it's the state of
computing in the UK I believe we call it
traditional computing anyway it's the
legacy system we have no idea what it
does but a couple of years a couple of
times a year it gives us the right
answer to something to do with the Sun
you know and people look at it go
did they build it just as you do with
legacy system how did they build it what
were they thinking yeah exactly legacy
but M is for monolith monolith us one
stone it's immoral and clearly what
we're looking for is something that is
more easy easily fluidly easy to
rearrange small stones rearranged now
sometimes when I put this slide up if
he's talking about micro-services you
know what if it makes you feel good yes
I'm talking about micro-services yeah
honestly I'm talking about any
decomposition pick a decade pick a
modularity class-based encapsulation
components whatever all of these are
trying to say the same thing don't build
one big thing that's all they're all
trying to say break it up into little
pieces subsystems that can evolve
independently and all this kind of stuff
it's the same message but just doing
that it's not gonna give you magic you
know most here I'll give you most
companies micro service architecture so
there's this whole notion what you've
got to do here is this is the debt this
is the friction this is the whole idea
that when we just go F equals MA a is
for agile a is to do with rate of change
in the long run every program becomes
rococo then ruble what we can appreciate
is that when we are talking about this
it's not about the speed it's about the
reason it's it's not even about the
velocity once we clarified that when we
talk about agility it is about that it's
the ability to rate of changes the next
derivative it's acceleration can I
change my velocity how quickly can I do
that it is not the velocity itself it is
how quickly can I change that is what we
mean by agility so I'll close with this
idea you know you want to reduce your
mass reduce your debt reduce the drag on
things but encounter this thought a
number of years ago which I thought was
quite a bit quite an interesting one
why do cars have brakes now there's a
very simple answer to this which is
obvious and also correct cars I break so
you can slow down okay that's one aspect
of it
there's another answer which is not so
obvious but is also correct cars have
brakes so you can go faster now this is
the more interesting one because it's a
simple thought experiment how fast would
you want to go in a car that had never
brakes like fine I'm good I'll walk you
know there's a point here when we to
start talking about a number of these
practices and people say oh you know but
if I do this if I do code reviews do I
do if I do unit testing if we do if we
do a retrospective if we do this this
will slow us down
uh-huh and sometimes people come to me
and say well Kevin people keep saying
that this will slow and slow it slowed
us down and what they're looking to me
is the answer no it's fine and I say
yeah it'll slow you down like I'll crap
but that's a good thing it slows you
down over a particular thing over a
particular time horizon remember time is
the bit we're not very good at it slows
you down over a particular time horizon
so that your broader time horizon
becomes faster I don't actually care
what happens in the the minutes the
hours and the days if we slow down a bit
if we're playing if we're playing the
game of software development normally
what we're producing lasts and lives in
the months and the years that's the bit
that you want to be hitting what happens
in the little level that's that's
maneuvering that's finding your
direction so with that thought I hope
that's convinced you and agility is not
speed thank you
[Applause]